I interviewed this guy recently
talking about animal stuff.
He,
uh,
he was doing his phd in University
of Pennsylvania and he was working in
psychology,
but there were chimps involved
in his research and so they,
like,
they would come into these cages,
but they had this big area
outside back behind the cages.
Right.
We're so like at night they would go hang
out and there were trees and stuff and
whatever.
So he would hang out until everybody
went home and he was alone.
And then he'd sneak back into
the area where the chimps were.
And he told this hilarious story
where he's with his champion.
He'd let go back there and you know,
smoke a joint at the end of the day.
And the chimps are wondering,
right.
And one day this chimp comes over and
sits down next to him and he's smoking a
joint and the chimp reaches,
no,
he has not get this champion.
The joke to the gym.
No,
it just hits it.
It gives it back to,
oh my God,
that,
that would be the greatest
video ever on youtube.
But Dude,
get,
there's one of a chimp fucking a frog.
Have you ever seen him at all?
I have is kind of sad.
Yeah.
Not for the chimp,
but,
but one of a chimp
smoking joint with a dude.
Especially a hippie.
Right.
Don't be the ultimate.
Don't bog garden man.
And if he did Bogart or
what are you going to do?
You know,
give the chimp to joint.
Shut the fuck.
Exactly.
Where rips your arms off.